with a promised wind years of decadence
and decline far right president Javier M
was sworn in on
Sunday in his inaugural speech he
expressed the hope that change has
finally arrived but he also warned the
country the next few months will be
difficult there's no alternative but to
implement austerity this will have a
negative impact on jobs salaries poverty
there will be
stagflation but it's not very different
from what we've seen in the past 12
years present at his inauguration was
Ukrainian President volodimir selinski
also attending Ultra nationalist
Hungarian prime minister Victor Orban
and Brazil's conservative former
president J bolsonaro in line with M's
ideology Juan Angel says he's ready for
what's coming next he carries a chainsaw
which became a symbol during the
campaign of how melee will imp Implement
austerity measures in
Argentina Malay will pass a series of
laws immediately and reform the taxes
that suffocate us he says how can we
have all this land that grows so much
food and the state takes away 60% in
taxes people are poorer every day
Argentina has had a history of economic
troubles and many are concerned about
the impact austerity measures will have
on the population poverty rates are
already almost 45%
kavier M says he has the support of the
people to implement a shock economic
plan to cut down government spending and
fight inflation he's promising to
transform Argentina but there fears that
implementing that plan could generate a
much bigger
crisis for now there is hope and
excitement among those who voted for
him Thea alj buenos
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer